what was it colbert who said reality is
a left-wing bias you know what 15 or so
years ago
maybe it did back then but today when i
pull up you know
uh cnn and they just say no evidence of
fraud
at all and then i literally have a sworn
affidavit
six of them all dropped at one time well
witness testimony under oath is is
is evidence the media is lying about
this stuff
just because you mentioned him real
quick as a sideline who do you think is
the first of these
comedians or show hosts you know the
existing ones today
who basically just made their uh milk
and honey out of
trump for the past four years which of
them gets the acts first samantha b
it has to be right i mean it's just
they're all so bad and they're spread so
thin and their jokes are the same
and they're so tired and everybody's i
mean frankly colbert was very close to
being fired i believe just because of
his
ratings at the time prior to trump
getting elected and turning so political
and yep you know and i i mean i've loved
colbert during his career i've met him
and he's been
very kind to me and that kind of thing
but at the same time it's like you
became so one note and so partisan and
so politicized
you stopped making jokes and and to me i
look at that
whole situation and it's like can we
maybe get some good comedy back in here
you had ryan long in here the other day
he's hilarious if i've interviewed
before too he's absolutely hilarious you
see the instagram just pulled his video
down
whoa really which one three days ago
which video it was pulled down
but it's on youtube no he was like guess
he got to go to youtube to see my new
video that
instagram pulled down oh my gosh but
he's a good example of
like there's so many comedians who
i mean and many of them are are leftists
you know but comedy itself is anti-woke
in in
all of its respects i mean it's designed
to cut people down it's designed to
you know make these points and to me
looking at this landscape
of hackery just we deserve a show that
actually makes us laugh
at the end of it i think firstly because
comedians are smart and that these
people have given up i think a lot of
people
on the left that are crazy and you're
like have they given up it's like they
got to a puzzle
like okay it's a d you get to a puzzle
and it's so complex
you can't figure it out and you're just
like i don't know and then you choose
bash as your option and you just
smash it to get through and that's what
they're doing they're going woke and
they're just
bashing because it's it's the
military-industrial complex
the pharmaceutical industry all these
industries the media
the manipulation they're hearing
different things is so confusing to
these people
that they're just giving up and then
they're just choosing so go woke
let's just go so ryan long's video was
white women say go back to hating white
men okay so i
actually was doing really well i just i
had just saved that on
on my youtube before i came over here
today to remind myself to watch it
but that's that's crazy they pull
something like that that's
that sounds hilarious obvious jokes but
you know what they allow
they'll well i'm not gonna get into it
they they allow bodily fluids and and
certain things
like that what they choose to allow and
not allow is really weird
like honestly in my opinion the nipple
thing is kind of funny
there's like they're so they're kind of
amusing women who take
um like they're like vinyl stickers of
male nipples
over their nipples and that's approved
by instagram what
because like because the rules are like
this weird system where it's like male
nipples are okay female aren't the heck
right it's kind of it's weird isn't it
it's like i just gotta allow the nipple
man
i guess you have to allow it's i don't
know what you do because it makes no
sense that they do that because then it
looks like they're just topless anyway
you know
you're still insinuating i think the
simulated nudity is just like nudity
right
i don't know that's how it's treated our
minds i think the rules are all really
weird
yes but but again stupid rules we're
surrounded by stupid rules and
sometimes they have the force of
government behind them but we're
increasingly surrounded by stupid rules
from places that really ought to be more
in the business of just like
we're a place where you can charge for
your newsletter all right
so so this is funny right it's always
been the liberals that were like the
corporations
the corporations and you know we gotta
tax the companies and
stop them and the government is good
then for a long time it was always the
conservatives saying no the free market
is okay the corporations are not evil
and the government
i'm speaking generally of course now
it's
the democrats saying but my private
business
it's like you sound like the koch
brothers and they and they think you're
they all think you're stupid
i mean jeff bezos you know yeah you know
it's like oh
amazon is viewed as horrible that's so
bad i'm gonna buy the washington post
with basically my money i found
with my couch oh and let's put democracy
dies and darkness at the top right at
the top
and we'll have all these stories bashing
trump and we'll you know market it
through amazon it's like a bonus to
people
meanwhile we're going to put out a
business small businesses all over the
place
and we're going to crush them when it
comes to ip we're going to engage in all
of this negative behavior
and you're not going to care because
we're just anti-trump we're this guy the
fascists we're fighting them but so this
is why i think we're on the precipice
well i can't keep using that analogy i
said before i feel like we've splattered
on the ground we felt the precipice we
went over a long time ago
we were falling for a long time smack
the ground this country has been split
in two
and you've got people i i have more than
two it's fracking no no
it is but just speaking generally the
people who supporting joe biden
who are supporting the lockdowns and
there's a large overlap not not every
single but the venn diagram is pretty
you know tightly compact
allowing private businesses to take away
to to monopolize the commons
that is the most anti-leftist thing i've
ever heard but left supports it
not all leftists but for the most part
they deny the censorship is even
happening
they say things like it's a private
business they can do what they want and
i'm like
bro the conversations we have the places
that's called the commons it's the area
where it's supposed to be like for all
of us to work and live together the left
was always about defending that
now you're saying but private business
when they censor somebody take away
their banking
or even in some instances kick them out
of their apartments which has happened
to some people
that's how crazy things are getting
they're supporting it so you know what i
see
stupid and complicit people the priests
of the cathedral who know what they're
doing to manipulate these people
and then you end up with the i guess you
call it the red pill
that's the that's the analogy they use
it's not not all conservatives
i think conservatives were the ones who
woke up to this a long time ago because
they were being lied about quite a bit
but then you end up with disaffected
liberals people like me you're certainly
no conservative you're
further left than i am on a lot of
issues and you would be considered right
wing for a lot of things that's insanity
i it is it is look at you you're you're
a hippie dude shirt with long hair and
then
your right wing dude but this is right
they're gone they don't mean it of
course
they're vague but think about what's
happening now what is
someone to do when you are watching
amazon eviscerate the working class
laughing while they do it democracy dies
in darkness
as he spits in your face and they
advocate and
and and fund politicians who say it's
against the science but we're going to
destroy your life your small business
your family
we're going to tell you to wear a mask
in your own home between bites but
we're going to go out and party like
gavin newsom what's a regular person
going to do when they see that over and
over again
and they know because they're listening
they're paying attention people are
going to explode man
i was on uh fox news earlier today
in the noon hour and they were talking
about nira tandon
the appointee or the the expected
appointee to
uh head the omb office of management
budget underneath joe biden
uh and nira is obviously somebody who
you know about and uh is uh
russia very controversial when it comes
to both her association with hillary
clinton her activities running the
center for american progress her general
trollishness
toward people online and as the
democrat who was on the show leslie
marshall was defending her
she said you know she's backed by you
know is qualified by such a diverse
you know coalition of people including
hillary clinton and bill crystal
and i just and i literally i literally
said you can find this clip i
started going like into my microphone
just for people don't know who's bill
crystal
the former the former head of the now
defunct uh weekly standard
but also someone who you know is also a
major neoconservative figure
you know as argued for wars all around
the world
and very similar to hillary to me it's
well but i said look you know the fact
that you think that these two people
coming together to back near a tandem is
a mark in her favor
you know tells us a lot about what this
where this administration is going which
is what i
here's what i honestly think we have we
have a situation where
the the america last foreign policy the
people who
view everything through the global
sphere as opposed to what is in the
interest
of the american people who view war as
something that we should go
into you know on the other side people
who view war as something that we should
go into very reluctantly very rarely and
always with
the interests of americans and the
american uh
and american stability uh you know at
heart in other words
you know there's a higher level of
threat from the cartels than from a lot
of these
countries in africa that's a side point
but the
the point being i think that that's now
moved into this new
this center-left globalist uh
coalition that biden wants to form and
that the kamala harris folks wants to
want to form in his stead
uh which is we're going to be good to
big tech we're going to be good to big
wall street
we're going to do everything that they
want in terms of of globalism and get
back into
uh you know the paris climate accords
which china likes more than us
which you know get back into the iran
deal you know get back into all these
other things that other places want that
don't look out for american interests
and they really think that they can hold
that together
with the glue of progressive wokism
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time